[Ukraїner
Експедиція]
[Вашківці,
Буковина]
Доброго дня.
Що цікавить, хлопці?
Є такі з зеленими хусточками, а є такі з чорними.
Пампулисті, із великими носами, з губами великими, з бровами.
Будьте здорові.
Будеш бити - знаєш хоть кого.
[Сміх]
Добре—добре.
Маски робили з шкір, овечих шкір.
Во
Ну, більшість дотримуються колишньої маски,
але, усерівно, то вже не то.
80-ті роки і 2013 рік:
які були, й які є.
Дід, Баба
Оце є був засновник пан, пан  Петрен був засновником цеї Маланки
Так щоби розвеселити себе і свою сім'ю,
він запрошав маланкарів.
Котрий кут перемагав, він давав там бочку меду, бочку пива.
І целий рік він був, та як допомагав тому кутові.
У нас Вашківці поділені на чотири кута.
І вони збираються і борються.
Котрий кут кого потруть, перетрутять.
Не б'ютси нічо так— борони Боже рукоприкладство.
Просто тручєют
І тоди колядуют під хатою, танцюють.
До хати там, господар трошечки грошей дістане,
Як кажуть, «фуршетний стіл» чуть-чуть і йдуть до другої хати.
Істина Переберії щоб
\з підручних/щоби з підручний матеріалів перевдітися за швидко
і щоб тебе не впізнали.
Дивіться.
Вам ці чотири,  так як ми казали.
Усі звикли, що він або «Пані» або «Алла Пугачова».
Я вже йому кажу: "Васю, ну уже роки всі тебе впізнають.
Ти не вспів дійти,  там до тої де вони збираються, - кажу - тебе вже знаю, що це ти ідеш" .
Кажу: «Давай щось інше». Передіваємо ми його на бабу.
Усі чекають на «Аллу Пугачову» — нема.
Да онди стоїть збоку, а вони: «Де Василь?
Ну де та Пугачова?  І де та Пугачова? І нема».
А ми сидимо — сміємося, бо він вже є.
Кажу: «Кого чекаємо? Та вже пішли».
«Та ще ж Василя нема».
Та не лиш я, то всі \ та то багато/мужики, мужики більшість \переодягаються у бабів/ на бабів та.
Ну на паню, на бабу, на циганку си перевдівають .
Ну як хто шо придумає собі.
Кіко мені предлагали шоби я був медведем. Я казав:" Нє".
Шоб мені статура позволяла шоб ше кожух убрати - то ведмідь віходе
То лиш цево. Нє— нє. Не треба. Мені не треба. Я не буду в то перевдіватися.
Не буду. Всьо.
Я не любітєль ведмедів.
Отаке якесь трохи таке.
Інтелігенція, як то кажуть.
У мене була така ситуація
ну як хлопець з дівчиною та й вже було заручення. Всьо.
Ну і тут сі попадає: треба було їхати за перебраний в друге село - Замостя.
Боже... Вона тут же кіпішує: «Всьо, всьо цего весіля не буде! Всьо!»
Ну коротше дійшло до того я кажу: «Слухай ,
ми розійдемося, але я переберію не залишу.
Всьо. Аби ти знала.
Ми розійдемося, жити не будемо.
Раз ти, ти цево...
А я - без цего не можу...Розійдемоси.
Вібирай або ми розходимося, або я буду перевдіватися».
І так вона каже: «Ладно.
Зараді цего сім'я не буде рушитися».
Оце є Маланка.
Це дві Маланці, це — Українка.
Це хлопці. Сугубо хлопці си перевдівали.
Перебираємося ми на бабів. Беремо обичніні маски баби.
Ну та й йдемо беремо якесь, якесь вишите, вбираємо та й ідемо.
Ідемо трохи в місто до нас, там по селі трошки походимо,
по хатах, до друзів, яких ми знаємо.
\І будем зажигати/Будем трохи зажигати. Да
Прийшов час, шо не було де взяти маски.
Був один майстер, так він то помер
і він нікому то не передав.
Прийшов прекрасний один вечір. Думаю:" Всьо с купив.
клей купив, матеріалу нарубав собі
і начєв. Одну сів робити маску.
Сама форма  — вона йде з глини.
Тогди на глину накладаютьси гіпсовочні бинти.
Я начинаю з гіпсовочних бинтів.
То обкладаються два слої.
Відтискаються губи там.
І обкладається воно потом, кладе си висихати.
І воно вісихає. Потім я здоймаю, здоймаю з цієї глини гіпс.
І на цей гіпс тогди накладаю, ліпи си , клей ПВА бере си
і отако кусок матеріалу, і накладаєсе на носку
Дуже-дуже багато ще беру я старих масок.
Я роблю реставрацію: там підліпив, туди переліпив - всьо вже...
Помалювали.
І от даже я беру люба маска, маска яку він мені зробив
і дивлюся: «Не це би була гарна циганка з цієї маски,
і вже малюю більш її таку смугляву, більш кучері чорні такі,
щоби оце би була гарна циганка. Ну так я
Береться та маска і от, ну от...
Коли береш - фантазія сама. Воно само тобі підкаже, що воно хоче
Для мене понад усе - Маланка.
Це перебераннє, це ліпити маски.
Я просто люблю.
Я сідаю і я успакаюваю си
Ну хоч би який був нервовий, я собі сів - я собі то ліплю.
У мене настрій святковий. Я...
Я вже чекаю з нетерпіння.
Повірте...
Це раз у рік.
Муси бути.
Це такого не може бути, щоб її не було.
[звуки свята]
[Автор проєкту
Богдан Логвиненко]
[Продюсерка
Оля Шор]
[Режисер
Микола Носок]
[Оператори
Олег Сологуб,
Павло Пашко,
Олександр Портян]
[Режисерка монтажу
Марія Теребус]
[Звукорежисер
Павло Пашко]
[Субтитрувальниця
Богдана Силюк]